ranger en bonjour bonjour merci nous
accueillir à europe 1 pour la seconde
fois d'ailleurs on a vraiment de la
chance vous êtes notre heureux notre
rendez vous annuel voilà on va faire un
peu un point si vous voulez bien déjà
sur votre carrière qu'est ce qu'il ya
comme changement l'émission de télé
devient mensuelle tous les premiers
lundis du mois donc ça c'est un énorme
braille et en même temps une grande
satisfaction mais oui j'imagine qu'on a
les moyens d'aller faire de
l'investigation la 22e semaine de
recherches sur chaque sujet ah oui très
excitant oui ça c'est extraordinaire
l'ombre d'un doute l'ombre d'un doute
surfer sur france 3 ici europe 1
l'émission continue tous les jours de
crise et puis il ya un nouveau
rendez-vous à 6h25 dans la matinale de
trop le matin là où il me restait que ça
et donc c'est rigolo alors c'est quoi le
principe de cette émission ce lieu sur
l'éphéméride du jour en fait c'est la
date du jour historique bien entendu ils
vont donc ce nouveau lit et puis la
sortie de ce magnifique livre françois
1er et donc c'est une biographie il a
mené sa biographie d'un essai
biographique j'ai pris les grands
événements du règne de françois 1er et
j'ai essayé de démontrer que françois
1er n'était pas le grand est le bon roi
que l'on pense j'ai fait en quelque
sorte un réquisitoire c'est un
réquisitoire qui s'assume comme tel
c'est le travail d'un procureur pour
démontrer qu'on a de ce roi une fausse
image on présente françois 1er comme le
grand roi de la renaissance messieurs un
personnage qui est le père des lettres
le restaurateur des arts l'inventeur de
toutes sortes de choses lui qui a fait
venir
je démontre que tout ça est faux exit a
fait venir léonard c'est sa mère louise
de savoie il n'était pas du tout le père
des lettres au contraire il a instauré
la censure il a interdit l'imprimerie
pour ce qui est du restaurateur des arts
il y aurait beaucoup à dire et alors
surtout c'était un mauvais père mauvais
mari un mauvais frère un très très
mauvais fils et puis c'était disons le
un
administrateur absolument insignifiant
un très mauvais chefs de guerre
puisqu'il a quand même perdu l'une des
pires défaites de l'histoire de france
de pavie et que si ça nous est arrivé
que trois fois en tout dans l'histoire
de france il a été capturé par les
allées oui c'est complètement incroyable
été pris en otage on sait même pas s'il
a été fait prisonnier oui les
prisonniers par charles quint il était
dans une prison terrible le donjon de
l'os laura naissent à madrid oui il a
failli mourir d'ailleurs à deux reprises
et il va pour sortir de la signer un
traité à la série off c'est inouï un
traité qui s'appelle le traité de madrid
qu'il ne respectera pas du tout et au
moment où il le signe il dit à ceux qui
sont autour de lui je signe ce traité
mais je n'ai pas l'intention de
respecter c'est un cas unique dans
l'histoire comment il avait le mérite
d'être franc ah oui ça se voit là il est
d'un culot moi je dirais absolument
inouïe a créé puis surtout il laisse en
otage sakho contre son départ ses deux
fils aînés donc françois et henry qui
vont passer quatre ans en prison très
jeune il ont cette évidence et çà et là
demain c'est ce qui est terrible c'est
qu'ils vont être vraiment au des
parutions otages d'état donc il arrive
avec 60 servi de trame est mais très
vite ça va se transformer en véritable
prison puisque leur père sitôt rentré en
france relance la guerre contre
l'empereur eh oui c'est comme si ces
enfants n'étaient pas en otage oui comme
s'il n'allait pas pâtir de ces actes c
est grave ans complètement parce
quelqu'un qui s'est toujours moqué de
tout et de tous il n'avait qu'une qu'un
seul intérêt s'était lui-même en fait et
l'a démontré constamment dans son règne
il est obsédé par son propre intérêt par
ses propres plaisir c'est quelqu'un qui
a été très mal élevé des ongles mais oui
donc par sa mère la fameuse rizki en
fait vous le dis dans ce livre là
complètement adulé a dû lui elle adorait
onu de qu'il était au berceau alalalala
lui à fait imaginer qu'il était un
demi-dieu sa soeur marguerite même chose
1 n'était pas en reste et puis
finalement elle avait très envie 7,7
louise de garder le pouvoir mais bien
sûr donc finalement elle lui a donné des
envies qui est pas les moyens d réalisé
exactement en fait l'ua
la mise sur un piédestal elle a porté
sur le trône elle a voulu king qu'il
donne l'image d'un grand et bon roi oui
c'est tout son césar triomphant comme
elle disait vrai mais à côté de ça
effectivement c'est elle qui garde le
pouvoir déjà et puis surtout elle l'a
très mal formés c'est quand vous dites à
un enfant pendant toute sa vie qu'il est
plus fort le plus beau le plus doué et
le plus et caetera et caetera et finit
par le croire surtout que la première
chose qu'il fait lui c'est d'aller mener
la guerre derrière les alpes à marignan
et que le dire le hasard parce que c'est
un peu un hasard mais en tout cas les
circonstances font qu'ils gagnent la
bataille
ah oui alors ça s'est monté à l'aide et
je dis bon ballon donc c'est vrai je
suis vraiment le plus fort on a vu que
les 31 ans qui ont suivi n'allez pas lui
donner raison oui et alors à décharge
peut-être il a il a un comportement
d'enfant je trouve d'enfants gâtés
bonjour à tous et bon rythme à dieu n'a
jamais connu principe de frustration
spécialement et puis donc tout tout lui
est dû à je regrette de ne pas avoir
d'ailleurs ça c'est intéressant parce
que c'est ainsi un jour je réédite le
livre je rajouterais ce détail je crois
que c'est vrai que sur un plan
psychologique il n'a pas connu le
principe de frustrer mal à rester dans
le reste du plaisir c'est ça en ruine on
saigne les français à blanc pour
organiser la plus grande récession
jamais fait dans toute l'histoire de
france un camp du drap d'or qui est une
chose extraordinaire il fait venir le
roi d'angleterre on le couvre de cadeaux
de grâce et c'est tout ce qu'ils
trouvent à faire ces deux gamins faut
dire qu'ils ont à faire et dont ils vont
ils vont se mettre à lutter ensemble et
autres entrepôts et l'autre le colosso
dirait l'autre et aucune fait un
croche-patte ce terrible donc l'humilie
chez lui c'est quand même pas très
intelligent de la part forcément
intelligent mais c'est un gamin de 5 ans
qui joue exactement alors justement ce
pas c'est par hasard que votre livre
sorte là pour début 2015 l'antarctique
c'est le cinquième temps déjà alors on
s'attend à tout ah oui de 5e se voyait
déjà les livres commencent à pleuvoir
les
libéraux spécial la d'historia etc
puisque évidemment 15 115 2015 cinquième
centenaire de l'avènement du roi et
cinquième centenaire de son sacre le 25
janvier et le cinquième centenaire de
marc ignore le 13 mai donc ça fait
beaucoup d'adversaires un demi
millénaire pour célébrer celui qui passe
pour un des grands rois de l'histoire de
france il fallait que dans ce concert de
louanges il y est en quelque sorte un
grain de sel 1 qu' un petit son
détonnant bas c'est le mien ce livre
c'est un certain et c'est ouais mais le
but est de démontrer que cela on nous
dit sur françois 1er n'est pas la vérité
est que ce roi était gelé baptisé ainsi
un roi de chimie voilà un what she mais
alors qu'est-ce que vous le dire parce
mme roy de rêve du réalisme
qui a vécu dans ce rêve manas toute sa
vie exactement et puis là il le pauvre
il meurt seul moment il n'a pas aimé
grand monde mais il n'a pas été très
aimé ça c'est intéressant parce que vous
savez quand aucun 119 charles quint est
élu sur le trône du saint-empire romain
germanique ou donc ça va être bien sûr
pour françois 1er un terrible désastre
ça parce que lui voulait être élu
empereur et c'est finalement son
concurrent le roi d'espagne qui
deviendra son ami jean le cam et à
partir de là ça devient son ennemi pour
la vraie vie pas là et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que nous avons nous en
france et c'est ce qu'on nous apprend
dans les manuels c'est ce qu'on vous
apprend à l'école nous avons l'image
d'un roi françois 1er tous de lumière de
réussite et de grandeur et d'un empereur
charles quint qui était une sorte de
petit personnage malabry leur abri c'est
qui est déplaisant mais si vous regardez
la réalité je regrette mais c'est le
contraire celui qui trahit tout le monde
celui qui ne tient pas sa parole celui
qui qui en en mène constamment son
royaume dans le mur c'est françois 1er
est celui qui a une grande et belle
vision noble qui poursuit son dessin
c'est charles quint est effectivement
vous avez raison de souligner
l'aspect essentiel de leur mort
respectives vous avez d'un côté françois
1er qui meurent d'abord à cros il avait
un cancer des testicules il était ça
faisait deux ans qu'il pouvait plus
s'asseoir c'était absolument atroce il
bien sûr cette maladie est gênante elle
est horrible et donc on ne se presse pas
son chevet et puis alors sa soeur est au
couvent c'est bon ça m'a tant ses traits
sa femme déjà alors la première scène
est ma télé
la deuxième ne veut plus lui parler
quant à sa propre mais très sale n'est
obsédé que par une chose soit devenir la
suite il est seul sur ce lit de douleur
il meurt dans des circonstances et son
fils son propre fils est devenu son
ennemi vous imaginez mais là c'est assez
bizarre parce qu'il meure assez content
lui finalement oui je n'ai pas faim je
n'ai pas de remords je m'en contente
mais voilà pourra tant mieux pour lui
oui ben c'est ce qu'on dit ça c'était
j'ai envie de dire ça c'est la
communiquer les paroles pour la
postérité les que la réalité c'est qu'il
n'aimait pas ce fils qui ne l'avait
jamais mais qui lui avait fait toutes
les crasses possible pendant son
existence et qui ne va lui laisser
royaume qu en très mauvais état le début
du règne d'henri ii est une chose
terrible et puis à côté de ça vous avez
charles charles quint qui lui amener
tout son toutou ses dessins il n'a pas
réussi à instaurer la chrétienté
universelle c'est un bon ça c'était
peut-être un peu trop ambitieux mais en
tout cas ils abdiquent ses couronnes il
donne la couronne de lempiras son frère
la couronne d'espagne à son fils mais
lui il se retire dans un très beau
monastère verdoyant en estrémadure
séjour il va finir ses jours en paix au
milieu ça fasse beau m'appeler rebond au
milieu de sa collection de pendule c'est
formidable un du oui il collectionnait
les pendules aller sans crainte et steve
mais dites moi tout ce qui a été acquis
dans la monarchie finalement c'est lui
qui l'a fait perdurer même à la limite
instaurer ou réinstaurer je pense à
saisir ils m'ont d atroces supplice la
roue et l'écartèlement en fait françois
1er a
d'une manière générale établi
l'absolutisme en france mais voilà alors
on peut dire que c'est une bonne chose
c'est ce que dit max gallo par exemple
dans son livre il dit le début de l'état
moderne le début de la monarchie absolue
c'est françois 1er avril enfin bon on va
la monarchie absolue contre quand on
regarde dans le détail ce ne sont pas
des bonnes choses c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire non c'est notamment cette
confusion entre les finances royales et
les finances publiques
c'est là
la mainmise sur tous les bénéfices
ecclésiastiques c'est très très
important ça représente 150 archevêché
évêché en france et 500 monastère dont
les revenus reviennent directement c'est
ce qu'on appelle la vénalité des offices
c'est à dire qu'on va se mettre à vendre
les charges dans la fonction publique
c'est tout ce qui concerne et alors là
c'est terrible la justice retenu du roi
avec séville à quoi la justice que le
roi rend lui-même ah oui et pour ce qui
est de la justice royale une justice qui
devient d'une dureté et même à la
violence et à renforcer ses services
saisis sont ressortis du fond des âges
voilà tout ce qu'on va et puis non c'est
sûr la cour cette courge hygro l'éthique
est absurde avec ce titre m réussi à le
dire voilà toutes ses maîtresses royal
c'est la première fois qu'on a des
maîtresses officielle dans l'histoire de
france bref donc voilà ce qu on
reprochera plus tard à louis xiv à louis
15 et accessoirement louis saez tout ce
qui va amener la révolution française
séné sous françois 1er est pire que ça
c'est en grande partie françois 1er qui
l'a mise en place et après ça on nous
dit c'est un grand roi ben moi je dois
dire que nous déplaire à ces grands rois
là on est bien d'accord vous allez me le
dire et le redire prochainement à
versailles parce que vous allez être
présent au fameux salon histoire de
l'insep ce moment et c'est vrai qu'au
salon de versailles vous avez tous les
auteurs enfin tous quasiment tous les
auteurs d'histoire qui sont là là c'est
un peu une fête pour nous tous c'est un
rendez-vous que moi je vois revenir tous
est essentielle
voilà les retrouver sains vienne 22 23
novembre on va le dire à la mairie
avait-elle des villes à versailles alors
il y aura des vous savez comme toujours
des conférant les conférences et les
rats moi je vais animer un certain
nombre de débats on est poli et puis je
parlerai aussi de françois 1er vous
craignez des détracteurs des amis de
françois 1er c'est je sais que c'est
déjà oui ou sans doute ils vont
apparaître pas d'elle il suffit de lire
encore une fois lu le livre de max
goeldi lui fait partie des amis trois
chaînes premier 13 des siens couronne à
françois le grand roi de l'histoire de
france moins d'un autre point de vue ils
ont essayé de rester factuels il est
factuel aussi il n'interprète pas les
événements soulever sa source est
d'ailleurs intéressant de voir ça l est
car nous montre ce qu'il ya eu de beaux
et deux premiers pas ce qu'avait aussi
bonne chose sûrement
on va rester sur ces paroles positives
franck merci beaucoup merci à vous bravo
pour ce livre passionnant et très vite
un très bientôt enfin franck